and guess what the professional assembly
said after until the land of Arabia
reverts to Meadows and rivers
your brothers and sisters at Islam yet
are establishing a one of its kind
Masjid Tower and Community Center in the
capital of Norway and they need our
urgent support now every person that
accepts Islam through the center every
river who learns about their deed and
calls their family to the worship of
Allah you will get the rewards inshallah
click the button to donate and earn this
tremendous reward inshallah Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him in many times
when we have debates and discussions the
one number one evidence that we use is
the prophecies that he made so specific
that in every single one of them have
nearly come true and even the signs for
the day of judgment sisters that
Scholars to say all neither all minor
signs have come and we are only waiting
for the major side brothers and sisters
one of the things the prophet married to
peaceful said was the following the
prophet salallahu said the last hour
will not come before wealth becomes
abundant and overflowing so much so that
a man takes zakar out of his property
and cannot find anyone except to accept
it from him until the land of Arabia
reverts to Meadows and rivers brothers
and sisters this is the prophecy of the
Prophet Muhammad peaceful and right now
as we speak brothers and sisters due to
be a heavy rains or whatever it may be
the lands of Arabia are starting to
slowly turn green against subhanallah
brothers and sisters the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him could have
made vague statement he could have made
it so vague but he's chose specifically
the Arabian Peninsula and that it will
go back to that
a land a Barren land like that going
back to Greenery who would have thought
that he is truly Allah he is the
messenger of Allah the one true God
deserving a worship and the final
messenger he has sent among many
Messengers he sent all I'm going to say
is let this be a wake-up call to us that
we put our trust in Allah in his
messenger and the righteous Deeds for
that day when we die brothers and
sisters that our Deeds continue do not
sacrifice this minuscule this little
moment that you're going to live here in
this life which Allah says that's going
to be like a day or a half a day may
Allah protect us till next time
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a sadakhajari for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
reward click the link and donate what
you can